you can pick your unworthy Rivals you
can pick any company for any reason and
say they're better than us you know what
can we learn from them
I'll give you a real life story that
really captured this for me
um and it's it's
um it's in the book but I'll tell it to
you
um uh
I spoke at a
education Summit for Microsoft
and then a few months later I was
invited to speak at an education Summit
for Apple
at the Microsoft Summit this is back in
the Steve Ballmer days
um in the Microsoft Summit
um the vast majority of the
presentations by the executives spent
most of their time talking about how to
beat Apple
at the Apple Summit 100 of the
presentations were how to help teachers
teach and how to help students learn
one was obsessed with beating their
competition the other one was obsessed
with advancing their mission
um
at the end of my talk at Microsoft they
gave me a gift
they gave me the Zune when it was a
thing this was Microsoft's response to
the iPod
and this little piece of technology I
have to say was really very very good it
was quite a good little piece of
technology it didn't work on an Apple so
I couldn't use it that's a different
problem
um but it was it was very good
um so at the end of my Apple talk I was
sharing a taxi with an apple executive
and I couldn't help myself I just had to
stir the pot
and I turned him I go you know Microsoft
gave me their new Zune and it is so much
better than my iPod Touch
and he turned to me and he said I have
no doubt
and the conversation was over
because he understood
this was an infinite minded organization
he understood
that sometimes
the your competitor will do something
better than you and sometimes you'll be
better than them there's no such thing
as winning or losing there's only a head
in behind and where Microsoft was
obsessed with beating apple apple was
obsessed without doing itself
and so the great irony is just a couple
years after that Apple released the
iPhone
so where Microsoft was obsessing with
how to make a better iPod Apple was on
to the next thing didn't even care and
that's the whole idea which is
absolutely study and learn from the
other players you see I don't even call
them competitors the other players in
your industry
split they're doing better like I said
it reveals your weaknesses and say we
can do better than than ourselves grow
eventually they no longer become worthy
of comparison anymore because you you
advance yourselves but the whole idea is
Apple was thinking about what they could
do next not how they could beat
Microsoft to get more market share for
an iPod
so learn from others and how you can be
better absolutely like I said their
strengths reveal to your weaknesses and
that's a gift